Season two of answer. The internet is here.
Bill Berg kicks things off and the card game is now available.
It's all the questions as up as you are to ask all your up friends,
get it at Barstool sports, Amazon, Walmart, and Spencer gifts.
Click the link below.
And the description. Hey, I'm bill Burr and I'm here to answer the.
[Inaudible].
All right. I'm not good at reading out loud. All right. Answer the internet.
Do you think you could throw a football farther than a 1940s Heisman
winner? No, never, never in my life. Could I, I just was,
I was good at catching things. I wasn't good at running, throwing. I mean,
I think the longest ever threw one was maybe 40 yards and I still feel that pain
in my shoulder. That's a really good throat. And then it was 30.
I just don't maybe I was on the metric system.
I don't remember if you guys are impressed. It was never impressive. All right.
Would you rather hit a home run as a pitcher score? That's a good one.
Score a goal as a hockey goalie or score. TD is alignment.
This is a no brainer pitcher demoralizing.
It's the pick six of baseball.
And my favorite one ever was when a what's his face cologne. Oh.
And when all those guys had the presence of mind to go into the,
into the locker room. So he wouldn't be there. Then they treated him like,
like this new rookie that was going to come up and he was going to hit 400 more.
That was my favorite thing ever.
And I always loved how seriously Pedro Martinez took hitting.
Like he actually used to take BP and all that. I loved it. All right.
Answer the internet. Would you rather see it? That's an old school show biz.
I keep saying the name of the big case. You cut this up.
The answer or the internet here.
Uh, would you rather always be hard or never be able to get hard?
My age? I thought you meant like ripped. Um,
would you rather always be hard or never be able to get okay.
Is there a way to remove the semen from my body so I can artificially become a
parent or whatever? What do they stick a needle in your balls?
Uh.
I'm going no and I'll tell you why I am.
I am old enough to know,
like you remember those devices of torture that they had,
where like they put you in it. And as much as it hurt, the more you move,
the tighter it got. That's what it's like to be in a relationship with a woman.
So you're not going to win.
And your dumb Dick is what leads you into it. So if I can neutralize my Dick,
I can't imagine the things I could have accomplished.
Debates.
The internet. I feel like I'm doing a old school talk show.
You have a choice between a sum of money and world peace.
How much money would you, would it take for you to give up world?
I go for world peace period and a story. No, no, no, no.
I'm doing great. I have enough of the Americans. I would absolutely.
I read a thing today. Know cover the paper. How,
when cashmere they doing something there and this woman's son 22 got bit by a
snake and couldn't get past the people to get into just seeing the mother's
anguish. There's a number. Wow.
I don't even think there's enough. I don't think you went big.
There's not enough wild wings. Do I got a number?
Be Tom cruise in a fight. No way.
Cause he would weird me out with how Intuit he'd be. He just gets into.
I would worry that he would do that. Val Kilmer, like that thing with his teeth.
And I don't think I'd be able to get over the fact that it was,
it was Tom cruise and I'm like,
why I get to see if he really knows how to fight all those, uh,
mission impossible. I think I would lose. I think I would lose, you know,
overwhelming with that Scientology energy. Right?
Uh, I know where the space.
I'd be like what the? And then I'd go beyond me. It would be it. Uh,
do you think the president jerks off in the oval office?
Not only do I think he does. I think they all do. And you have to,
as a man the first day, what can we do for you president?
And they already know what you're going to say. I uh,
would just like to have everybody get out of the office for about four minutes.
Thank you. And everybody knows what you're doing, you know?
And I think even the Illuminati shuts off their cameras,
that's probably like they're locked the door test as he jerked off in the oval
office. Yes. Yes he has. All right, good. We've got another one.
The Wars will continue.
All right.
Uh, answer, answer the internet. I want an old sport coat. Next time I do this.
Uh, if you find, if you found a porn online of your buddy
and his girlfriend, would you watch it? Would you say anything to him? No,
I wouldn't. Oh no. I would tell him I would not watch it. No way,
dude. That's weird.
Pause forever. No.
No. That's, that's a young person thing. Like,
like how polluted your hard drives are, you know,
the fact that you'd have your buddies come face in your head. I mean,
I don't know. That's why I never understood the two on one with another guy.
Do you know? I know I can't because it's somebody else's story.
I'll tell you the guy who it is and you got to ask them. All right. All right.
Answer the internet. Uh,
would you rather have no music for the rest of your life or have all
music be sung by your significant other?
Oh my wife's adorable and I love music. Yeah. W well, my wife,
she actually has a good voice. I'd ever sing. Oh, then,
um, no then he can't because that would be a double whammy, but after a while,
but if there was no music and he was the only one singing,
he would be the benchmark and he'd come out in a boxing ring,
like Sinatra at Madison square garden. How many are there? Jesus Christ.
it. This is what they get these, all these guys with their extra. Okay.
Didn't you listen to Dan show? I'm Hollywood bill.
I don't have time for this answer. The internet, um,
who would win in a fight in their prime?
Michael Keaton or Jon Bon Jovi.
Wow. Okay.
Dude. That's like when like, I don't know,
like ball state is playing Arapaho community college. It's like,
I don't know any players on these teams. I don't know how these guys fight.
Let's see Jon Bon Jovi in his prime. He had that hair.
You might keep his Batman lay your hands on me. I'm trying to figure it out.
I want you to say, what would you say Michael?
Keaton's prime was physically a night shift night shift over here.
If I were to work out for that, I would say this.
I would say that Michael Keaton in founder,
or when he played the cop and the other guys could beat Bon Jovi.
When he tried to buy the Buffalo bills. That's that's as far as I know,
I would go, Michael Keith, last one. Last one.
Before we take a break with your local sponsor, answer the internet.
Would you rather go back to being 18 years old, knowing everything?
Do I get Propecia this time? Uh, uh,
everything you know now or get a million dollars?
Would you rather go back to being an 18 year old? No way.
No, there is no number to go back to being 18 again. Huh? Yeah.
And music makes sense to me. I had those red locks.
Are you kidding me? Oh my God. And all the stadiums and all that,
then I would know what games to be at. Huh? I would go. Yeah, no,
I would go back to being 18 in a second.
What am I going to sit there and a jacuzzi with a cigar or be 18 again?
That's one of the easiest questions ever. Thank you, ladies and gentlemen,
this has been answer the internet.